two police officers pinned down agendy
valdo
santosh a black man they say was
resisting arrest
then they trap him inside the
smoke-filled trunk of their police car
look at that man there oh my god they're
killing him inside the car says one
witness
video of the incident went viral on
social media
protests have been held in his hometown
in bauba in northeastern brazil
and shock and outrage expressed across
the country
for years human rights activists have
accused police in brazil of
discrimination brutality and excessive
force on tuesday the day before santos
died dozens of people were shot dead
during a police raid on a criminal gang
in rio de janeiro
yes another massacre in a favela it's
truly shocking we cannot allow it to be
normal that the state enters a favela
and leaves with 20 or more dead
relatives of santos say he was unarmed
and suffering from heart problems and
schizophrenia
the federal highway police have opened
an investigation into his death in a
statement they said santos was actively
resisting the officers who pulled him
over
they immobilized him then used
instruments of lesser offensive
potential to contain him
santos was taken to the hospital doctors
say he was dead when he arrived at the
emergency room the police officers
involved have been suspended but many in
brazil fear this may be another example
of institutional brutality and racism
within the police
monaca yanakeval jazeera rio de janeiro